بدا الاف الفلسطينيين من مناطق الضفه
الغربيه منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر التوجه
الى مدينه القدس المحتله عبر عدد من
المعابر والحواجز العسكريه لاداء صلاتي
الجمعه الاولى من شهر رمضان المبارك وقد
اقامت سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه التي
نشرت عددا كبيرا من جنودها عند المداخل
المؤديه الى القدس بوابات خاصه لتنقل
المصلين من الضفه الغربيه ضمن شروط محدده
وفرضت اجراءات امنيه مشدده وهذه الصور
تاتينا اذا مباشره من حاجز اذا من
من بيت لحم اذا هذه الصور تاتينا مباشره
من بيت لحم وتوجه
المصلين في يوم الجمعه الاولى من شهر
رمضان المبارك
للصلاه في المسجد الاقصى الى القدس ضمن
اجراءات امنيه اسرائيليه مشدده
[موسيقى]
اذا وقد نشرت شرطه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
صباح اليوم نحو الفين من عناصرها في انحاء
مدينه القدس قبل ساعات من وصول عشرات
الالاف من الفلسطينيين من الضفه الغربيه
ومن داخل الخط الاخضر لاداء صلاه الجمعه
في المسجد الاقصى وعزز جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من وجوده على الحواجز العسكريه
حيث سيمنع الرجال دون الخامسه والاربعين
عاما من عبور الحواجز بينما سمحت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لعدد محدود من الفلسطينيين من
قطاع غزه بدخول القدس
حيث سيشمل ذلك الرجال ممن تجاوزوا الخامسه
والخمسين عاما والنساء ممن تجاوزنا
الخمسين عاما